in this video we will talk about the
meckel's diverticulum before beginning
make sure to hit the like button below
and don't forget to subscribe to have a
regular update about the upcoming videos
so let's get started a magazine
ridiculous a true diverticulum as it
contains all the three layers of the
intestine and it is formed by a
persistent proximal part of the vital
intestinal duct suppose this is a fetal
for gut and this is the anterior
abdominal wall and this is the yolk sac
during the fourth week of the gestation
there is a connection between the four
gut and the yolk sac and this connection
is known as the Vitello intestinal duct
or the VI duct it is also known as um
Philomath centric duct and during the
natural course of the gestation during
the ninth week this dub gets obliterated
and if it doesn't two conditions can
arise first of all the whole of the VI
doubt can be present and there is a
persistent connection between the
foregut and the anterior abdominal wall
this condition is known as the vital
intestinal fistula and second condition
may be that only the proximal part of
the VI duct can be present there is no
connection between the VI duct and the
anti abdominal wall and this condition
is known as the meckel's diverticulum
now let's talk about the rule of tools
for remembering the important stats for
the meckel's diverticulum its incidence
in the general population is about two
percent and most common location of the
meckel's diverticulum is two feet
proximal to the ileocecal Junction it is
mostly 2 inches in length and most
common age of presentation is around 2
years male-female ratio is around 1 is
to 2 and 2 types of ectopic tissue may
be present in the meckel's diverticulum
the gastric and the pancreatic now since
the meckel's diverticulum consists of
of the pluripotent cells which can give
rise to any type of cells the gastric
tissue is the most common which can
secrete the acid and can lead to
ulceration of the meckel's diverticulum
clinical features of the meckel's
diverticulum most patients having
meckel's diverticulum are asymptomatic
but if they present the most common
presenting complaint is painless rectal
bleeding which can be in the form of
Melina other complaints in meckel's
diverticulum can be due to intestinal
obstruction
they can also be volvulus or into
secession
meckel's diverticulum can also be
complicated by excess secretion of acid
which leads to acute diverticulitis how
the meckel's diverticulum is diagnosed
the most important test which we can do
to diagnose meckel's diverticulum is
technetium-99 / technique scan this set
test is also known as the meckel's scan
and it detects a topic gastric tissue
the other tests we can do to diagnose
meckel's diverticulum are the ultra
sonography and CT scan and talking about
the treatment the meckel's diverticulum
is treated only if it is symptomatic and
it is surgically resected thank you so
much for watching this video this was
pretty much all about the meckel's
diverticulum if you find this video
informative don't forget to hit the like
button and also subscribe to our channel
for further upcoming videos